kiss my ass and call me an idiot cause
that's exactly what i do if i stay in
this relationship
angela calls off her wedding to michael
once again i'll tell you why
in just a few hey my 90 day fans fam
it's melisia on the latest episode of
happily ever after
simmering problems boiled over for some
of the couples
[Music]
i'm going to update you on the biggest
must-see moments
kicking it off with why angela called
off the wedding
this time all right at the top of the
episode
she and michael went to premarital
counseling which is mandatory before you
get married in nigeria
should we start shall we start how did
you meet her
we met on facebook and i sent a request
uh from there we started talking
on the facebook they have many women
there why she
ah i don't know something just kept
pushing me to a
profile and i saw it i liked it is that
the man you want to marry
yes that last question came off a bit
shady
but for the most part the session went
well
they presented angela and michael with
three options of different types of
marriages
two where michael can have multiple
wives
this is where we're no we're not doing
that and
one where there is one man and one woman
but of course angela had to clarify
whether that option
still includes side chicks is he allowed
to have science love
[Music]
don't satisfy him angela satisfy him
sexually
if you are doing that his eye will not
be outside
[Music]
make him happy when he comes back the
food is ready
the bed is laid properly two tasks
permission total submission to
transformation
put in my mind i'm going no michael
knows no
well thankfully angela held her tongue
in front of the counselors
their marriage was stamped as qualified
but
as you probably assumed that submission
conversation
is going to come back up and it happened
in front of michael's aunt lydia
who the couple met up with to talk about
wedding planning
angela strutted into the restaurant in
her cute blue heels
and in usual 90 day fashion the dinner
started off nice
before i left i wasn't going to come i
was going to cancel but mama told me no
you know she said just go and bring
michael home
wow that is lovely yeah she approved it
oh yes that is very good of her but
before you knew it
and lydia asked how the counseling
session went and
this happened part of my culture will
still
be in the face not like i'm going to
change the coach he told me i don't mean
to have to retire i don't mind the
pressure yeah
it's part of it like the food aspect
submissive
i'm not being submissive you think
you're going to come over there
and live with me and i'm going to bow
down to you i am
not bound down to you or no living man
woman at all
eventually angela got a bit too heated
and decided it was time for her
to step away he has to respect his
culture
and y'all have to respect mine
baby needs to find a nigerian woman
that's it
you know and i'm going to the bathroom
and i'll be right back i didn't i didn't
know this was coming up no
you're doing this though don't raise
your voice at me in front of your aunts
don't do that do not do that
um don't you calm down don't do that
because she's sitting there
did i miss it did michael raise his
voice
because for the most part all i heard
was angela
you're doing this i love you don't raise
your voice at me in front of your aunt
don't do that angela is saying that she
wants this marriage to be 50 50.
and she doesn't want to be totally
submissive to michael
but she speaks to him as if she wants
him
to be totally submissive to her you can
tell that michael is just not a
confrontational person
but at this point he needs to stand up
for himself
his reluctancy to speak up makes me
wonder if he really
is just in it for a green card here's
what happened when angela came back
angela i'm very sorry i like you that's
fine
but with this kind of attitude
i don't know about your value
so we're done you need to think whether
you're gonna do what they want you to do
or what me and you've been doing for
three years i'm done
talking oh god it's been fun see you
later
i'll be at the house angie i'll be at
the house
angie i'm not doing it this wedding's
off
so there you go that's how angela called
off the wedding
this time around all right moving on to
our final
must-see moment carini who has clearly
not
been enjoying her time in the u.s locked
herself
in the bathroom i'm assuming to get away
from paul
every now and again she does this she'll
go back for locker seven there for like
four five six hours
then finally come out she's having a lot
of mood swings lately
and i feel really bad for i'm trying
everything i can but
it's difficult it's very difficult
whatever was going on between these two
got even worse because earlier this
month karini claimed that she was
granted
an emergency protective order against
paul
one day after he claimed in an instagram
video that carini was missing with their
one-year-old son
i hate that there's a baby in the middle
of all of this
i definitely hope they can work
everything out in a way that's
best for the kid alright well next week
on happily ever after
angela goes off on michael
and i'll tell you right now it's hard to
look at
you set your ass there didn't you care
where i went
will you calm down you reduce your voice
mother
i am who i am and you take it or leave
it treat me like
but you can't walk away from your aunt's
table get your ass get your
out and get your mamas the wedding's off
that's a lot that's a lot
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all mwah see
you next time